[Music]
both from Boston but the difference is
you really like the Boston accent I as
much as I love Boston I have to say I
don't miss the Boston accent because I
grew up with it and it was usually kids
about to beat me to death but you you
like the Boston accent I find it I find
it very sexy because I think maybe
because of all those like Ben Affleck
movies where it's like about Bank bought
the bank robbers are just trying to make
money they can support their families
and like they don't want to do it right
have to you right
and like I find that very appealing
because they're like you leave
Charlestown never come back you know
like that kind of thing just so it feels
very there something feels Noble to you
about it often portrayed as these very
gorgeous like six-packs AB blue-collar
dudes right and it just seems like they
say something and it seems like even
halfway smart and you're like you're a
brilliant genius but you mean if someone
with that accent says the sun's coming
up it must be daytime you think that
guy's brilliant Albert Einstein yeah
that's crazy I've never heard anyone say
that before now think of a six-pack
thing you the segment that you shot for
me one of the 50 cameos that we got was
you out walking your dog and I was
thinking I saw you know it's like oh you
feels like you like working out a lot
you're on the move a lot yeah you do do
you how do you motivate yourself you did
you shot it we shot it out and at Runyon
and you you look like you were gonna go
take a jog Conan stop being all over me
you don't work for me now and I was
trying to turn it into more than it was
thank you very much I I do people are
that's very sweet of you I do exercise I
jog but in order to work out the way
that I motivate myself and I've actually
used this in the show is I have to
pretend when I run that I'm in a
vengence bundu slabber Atlanta sees to
motivate myself because I what are you
talking about I can't just be motivated
and look how this is like good for my
health I should because I'm an actress
in Los Angeles that leg won't work for
me I'll just and bed so I have to be
like okay okay what am i doing okay
Michael Fassbender was my husband and
then we were in Central Park one day and
someone stabbed him because they hated
interracial couples and they got away
with it they got away with it and now I
have to go down to like Brazil and find
this Nazi who killed my husband Michael
better
wait so you're so you're training for a
5k to raise money to get in Canyon like
he's so okay so for instance you ever do
like push-ups cuz I'm trying to do 20
consecutive push-ups is my new thing
this summer no I'm just like it's a in
my mind it's a getting stronger montage
they should I find this guy right yeah
cuz you never know when the shit's gonna
go down you might happen when I tell
people this they then do it and it works
for them okay yeah but my mind wanders
too like I'm trying to avenge murder and
then I'm like hanging out with Beyonce
in my mind we're going shopping then
you're getting some frogurt